Je sais ça fait bizarre !
Les amis nous avons réussi il y a quelques jours à récolter 57 000 euros pour l'association Cé Ke Du Bonheur. Totalement grâce à vous qui avez fait une donation, qui avez partagé le live
ou qui avez contribué à ca d'une manière ou d'une autre. J'avais dit que si on dépassait dit les 50 000,
je me rasais la tête, en mode McFly. C'est chose faite. Attendez, attendez, attendez..
N'y a-t-il qu'une seule réalité, ou une multitude de réalités parallèles ? Peut-être que dans une autre réalité,
je suis pas youtuber mais je suis boulanger. Et que dans cette autre réalité je pense que dans une autre réalité je suis youtuber, et
pas boulanger. Les amis la vidéo sur les reptiliens vous avait énormément plu. Nous allons aujourd'hui
parler de l'Effet Mandela. Vous connaissez déjà peut-être, c'est très connu. C'est Fiona Broom lors d'une conférence en 2010 qui
découvre que Nelson Mandela n'est pas mort en prison mais qu'il est bel et bien toujours en vie. Bon malheureusement au moment où je fais
cette vidéo il est décédé mais à l'époque de la conférence non. Elle est alors sur le cul et elle demande aux gens dans la salle
s'il y en avaient qui pensaient comme elle qu'il était mort en prison, et il se trouve que la moitié de la salle pensait comme elle. Et l'autre
moitié savait qu'il n'était pas mort. Elle a donc appelé ça l'Effet
Mandela, et encore pour vous faire simple : c'est quand énormément d'individus ont un souvenir qui ne correspond pas à la réalité,
la réalité dans laquelle ils sont parce qu'il y a plusieurs réalités je vous le rappelle hein, dimension tout ca.
Il ya donc deux écoles : les gens très rationnels et très scientifiques, et les gens qui aiment bien croire au fait qu'on
peut switcher d'une réalité à l'autre sans même s'en rendre compte et que du coup on a des souvenirs liés à l'autre réalité. Alors, alors,
un peu de calme dans tout ça parce que là ça met le boucan dans vos cerveaux. Dernière chose avant de commencer à checker les
Effets Mandela. Il faut savoir que la mémoire c'est quelque chose de très complexe et que notre cerveau est loin d'être parfait, il a plein de
bugs de
modifications qui se font. Y compris dans vos souvenirs, vos souvenirs sont
modifiés, des fois même vous avez des souvenirs de choses qui ne sont en fait jamais arrivées.
Vous vous êtes approprié le souvenir d'un autre ou alors vous l'avez rêvé et vous croyez que ca s'est vraiment passé. Bref, il y a mille
explications vis-à-vis de ça, il y a beaucoup de recherches qui sont faites autour de la mémoire et c'est un truc assez
passionnant. Alors là vous pensez ce que vous voulez de ça, mais aujourd'hui on va checker les Effets Mandela. Premièrement,
l'assassinat de J.F Kennedy. Ils étaient six dans la voiture et pourtant tout le monde a l'impression qu'ils étaient 4. C'est très très vieux et
on s'en fout pas mal on va prendre des trucs plus actuels qui nous parlent un peu plus. La queue de Pikachu. C'est vrai, que dans
mes souvenirs,
elle a
peut-être un bout noir. Mais dans mes souvenirs très lointains. Et bizarrement c'est toujours relié à des souvenirs très lointains. Ou alors des souvenirs
tout simplement d'une autre réalité. Je n'ai pas conscience d'avoir changé de réalité, j'ai fait un saut quantique. Ceux qui ont autour de 20 ans, dans vos souvenirs,
elle a le bout noire ou pas la queue de Pikachu ? Non mais voilà qu'on se le dise, pour moi je pensais qu'elle avait le bout
noir,
effectivement, mais en voyant ça je me dis bah non, c'est ce Pikachu là clairement, le vrai. Ca, c'est une sorte de fake hein, c'est comme
les gens qui écrivent Squeezie avec un y au lieu de ie. C'est ce qu'on appelle des fakes. Je vois pas Pikachu tous les jours, et
je pense tout simplement que vu que  le bout de ses oreilles sont noirs, ton cerveau a envie de voir le bout de sa
queue noire aussi parce que c'est logique, c'est parallèle, c'est..voilà. On a un screen ici de la version jeu de Pokémon, et on
peut voir qu'il n'a pas de bout noire au bout de la queue.
C'est pas du tout le bout noir qu'on voit sur le dessin d'avant. Dans Pokémon Go il a pas le bout noir non plus. Là il a pas
le bout noir. Alors ce vieux Pikachu, qu'est ce qui s'est passé là ? Ma théorie, je pense juste qu'il a le bout des oreilles noires
Pikachu et que ton cerveau a envie de le voir avec le bout de la queue noire parce que c'est beau, c'est homogène, c'est joli.
Et moi je sais que j'adore tout ce qui est très parallèle, très symétrique et donc mon cerveau a
modifié le souvenir comme il avait envie de le modifier, et ça a donné ça. Alors il y a un truc qui me fait rire c'est genre dans un monde parallèle, tout
est pareil mais il y a juste Pikachu au bout de sa queue il a un truc noir. Tu sais genre il y a juste ça comme changement dans un monde parallèle.
Deuxième Effet Mandela, apparemment le bonhomme de Monopoly n'aurait jamais eu de monocle. Il est vrai, que je l'imaginais avec un monocle.
Car peut-être dans une autre réalité les concepteurs de monopoly ils se sont décidés à lui mettre un monocle, tout simplement. J'ai une théorie.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, le bonhomme de monopoly a un
costume, un chapeau, je sais plus comment on appelle ca bref c'est une tenue qu'on a
vu plein de fois dans plein de films, dans plein de séries. Le costard, la canne, la moustache comme ça, et le monocle. La vraie
version du bonhomme de Monopoly c'est qu'il a tout l'uniforme sauf le monocle. Pour moi, notre cerveau a juste l'habitude d'un stéréotype
et il a appliqué ce stéréotype au mec du logo de Monopoly, que tu ne regardes pas tous les jours on va pas se mytho. Même quand
tu prends tout Monopoly tu l'ouvres tu regardes même pas le mec alors qu'il est juste devant toi. On en vient donc à la question suivante :
le logo de monopoly n'a-t-il jamais eu de monocle ? Ou a-t-il un monocle dans une autre réalité ?
Bon ! Autre mystère. Ahh ! La
Joconde ! Est ce que dans vos souvenirs La Joconde sourit ou est ce qu'elle a une expression neutre ? Parce que le fait est que
La Joconde..non c'est pas la vraie Joconde ca. Elle a un très léger sourire comme ça. Et
apparemment, dans le souvenir de plein de gens, elle aurait une expression neutre sans sourire. Pour ma part, je l'ai toujours vu sourire.
Après
peut-être que dans une autre réalité elle ne sourit pas du tout. L'Effet Mandela ca touche et l'histoire, on l'a vu avec Kennedy, et aussi la
culture. Des paroles de musique qui changent, des dialogues de films qui changent. Et dans les dialogues de films il ya le fameux
Dark Vador, je crois que que c'est l'Effet Mandela le plus connu. "Obi-wan ne t'a jamais dit ce qui est arrivé à ton père."
"Oh il m'en a dit assez. Il a dit que vous l'avez tué."
"Non, je suis ton père."
Il a jamais dit "Luke, je suis ton père." ! Mais alors pourquoi ? Parce qu'on vient d'une autre réalité bien évidemment c'est un souvenir d'une autre réalité.
quand on raconte cette semaine à un pote on l'a
contextualise en dix ans luke je suis ton père tu englobe tous les éléments et juste avec cette phrase le mec comprend le twist de
star wars mark hamill lui même a fait les plateaux télé à mort après la sortie de star wars et on lui demandait des fois
de rejouer la scène et il disait lui même luke je suis ton père et non pas non je suis ton père pour la raison
que je viens de vous dire mais donc ça a
popularisé la phrase luke je suis ton père et on en a même oublié la vraie phrase qui a dans le film parce que des
gens qui disent look je suis ton père maintenant raconte enfui en passant est drôle y en a des masses c'est ma théorie après
peut-être combien de notre réalité dans laquelle dark vador des blues juste ton père n'ont pas non je suis ton père que dans cette réalité
lucas le visage de obi wan et obi-wan a le visage de l'udc on remarque déjà la queue depuis tout à l'heure on cite que
des vieux trucs bizarrement les faits mandela sait jamais sur un truc qui date de l'ère six mois c'est que sur des
vieux trucs vraiment ton cerveau a bien eu le temps de modifier ton souvenir alors dans blanche neige
on connaît tous la phrase miroir mon beau miroir mais elle ne dit pas ça elle dit en réalité
Oui miroir
Miroir magique au mur mais que c'est que ce bordel moi j'étais persuadée qu'elle disait miroir mon beau miroir alors pourquoi
et bien
cela peut-être parce que miroir magique au mur c'est beaucoup trop d'éléments à retenir pendant quinze ans après avoir vu cette scène que miroir mon
beau miroir bo est un mode qui utilisent régulièrement si tu es beau
C'est beaucoup plus simple de retenir
miroir mon beau miroir que miroir magique au mur ça sonne mal en plus là on est juste victime de notre cerveau qui nous joue
des tours avec notre mémoire à nos souvenirs et qu'ils aient modifié voilà après il est vrai
peut-être que notre réalité effectivement elle dit miroir mon beau miroir et non pas de miroir magique au mur nous ne savons parquet dans cette
autre réalité tout monde et sur dailymotion et plus personne et sur youtube
ok je suis sur le forum de reddit où ils ont fait un
topic mandela effect ou tous les gens témoignent de trucs qu'ils pensent être des effets modèle il ya la phrase très connus d'apollo 13
houston we have problème
Il ne dit pas houston on a un problème il dit houston on a eu un problème donc en anglais houston we've had
prolonge avons tant que français
nous c'est la même chose nous on utilise juste présent pour nous ça veut tout dire yes to pay as you go to the toy
lot n a ici
someone venu à octobre voilà la page officielle de la nasa propose les missions apollo 13 sites la phrase we've had
problème un peu après février 2007 la page aurait changé pour afficher la nouvelle phrase houston we have
troubles et lovell qui a dit cette phrase aurait dit lui même qui l'a dit houston we have
problème bon j'avoue c'est là enfin nous on s'en bat les couilles un peu quoi
les looney tunes sont apparemment tous on se souviendrait de looney
tunes alors que c'est looney tunes sera écouté je regardais et pour moi ça a toujours été les miennes et unsa à temps
Non c'était bien looney tunes effectivement peut-être que ça vient de nos barons qui savait pas du tout parler anglais
et qui disait les looney tout tu te mets devant les looney toons lucas comme ça fait des années
qu'on n'a pas vu le générique on s'est dit ah ben
notre cerveau souvient claude ménara disait tout parce qu'elle nous a dit plus de fois tout ce qu'on a vu le logo looney tunes et
notre cerveau a modifié le logo pour que cela corresponde à la prononciation de notes d'argonne c'est possible ou alors
notre réalité peut-être qu'il s'agit de lui mais tout ne s'est pas tu ne t'y fictivement ya aussi un effet mandela autour du film
iti vous souvenez itil
extraterrestes mois dernier je me situe pour jouer pour ceux de ma génération on sait que normand iti dans le film un moment il dit
iti téléphone maison l'extrait nous montrent qu'en réalité il dit iti maison téléphone voir ce qu'il en est et
Ita mais c'est flippant mais quand on voit ce que regardent et ghost est glauque quand même
Non non il dit it is
téléphone maison groix je me souviens bien par contre là par contre c'est sûr tout le monde se calme ne paniquez pas les enfants nés
dans les années 90 avaler sa place je sais que votre coeur d'enfant là est en train de s'emballer parce que vous êtes
révoltés parce que vous êtes en train de voir attendait continue regarder la scène peut-être que derrière ils rétorquent les enfants
y fifa
Voilà
donc effectivement ici il dit it is maison téléphone mais à petite fille elle dit il qui téléphonent maison elle
rectifie ce qu'il dit parce qu'ils partent vers l'anglais parce que notre planète est encore il apprend très vite et très fort utile c'est plus
logique
iti
téléphone maison ton cerveau a plus retenu cette phrase il a associé le moment légendaires ou utilise m'a parlé à ce que la petite fille
a dit tout simplement n'y a pas d'effets mandela latin
j'ai failli croire suite à cela j'ai failli y croire je me suis dit putain et tu mandela c'est incroyable et bien les amis c'est
la fin de cette vidéo je n'ai toujours pas de cheveux mais j'étais pas aller mais s'il vous a plu je suis content de parler
de l'effet mandela parce que c'est un truc assez puissant quand même c'est assez dingue de se dire que autant de gens ont un souvenir
complètement différent de la réalité et ils ont le même souvenir l'hypothèse de dire que c'est un souvenir d'une autre réalité et
estives et ça fait rêver tout parce qu'en plus on sait qu'il ya plein de réalités parallèles donc tu diras putain c'est dingue mais en
vrai j'ai quand même l'impression qu'avec les exemples qu'on a vu là en tout cas n'y a pas d'histoire de souvenirs d'une autre réalité c'est
juste ton cerveau qui a été influencé hier ou de l'autre en plus le fait que ce soit que des
vieux trucs tu ailles te montrent que des trucs qui date d'il ya très longtemps ou ton cerveau il a bien eu le temps de
modifier le souvenir de le remanier j'aurais kiffé qu'il ya un truc genre tu vois qu'il dote de six mois
genre à bas risque et jaune et qui attend baril a jamais dit ça il a dit
quelque chose et jaune et qui attend et là j'aurais fait quoi en tout cas ceux qui y croient croyait et ceux qui n'y croient
pas et n'y croyez pas on s'en fout mais bon voilà on aura des cantiques et un peu stuc la casse intéressante quand même je
vous fais plein de bisous j'étais assis vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire je garde mon chaîne vidéo portez vous bien
merci d'avoir gardé au revoir